I have the honor tonight of introducing
mr. David Satter a former Moscow
correspondent of the Financial Times of
London
he has written three books on Russia and
his first book age of delirium he turned
into a documentary which he showed to
students on Tuesday he has followed
Russian events for almost four decades
after Radio Liberty accredited satyr as
a correspondent in Moscow he was
expelled from Russia becoming the first
u.s. correspondent to be expelled since
the Cold War he is a fellow of the
Foreign Policy Institute at the Johns
Hopkins University School of Advanced
International Studies a senior fellow of
the Hudson Institute and a senior fellow
of the Foreign Policy Research Institute
in Philadelphia he has also been a
research fellow at the Hoover
Institution at Stanford University
Satur teaches a course on Russian
politics and history at the Johns
Hopkins University School of Advanced
academic programs and has been a
visiting professor at the University of
Illinois this weeks my classmates and I
have had the privilege of learning from
him about non-fiction writing and how he
went from being a police reporter in
Chicago to a cook foreign correspondent
in the Soviet Union because he always
finished what he started
Russia may not want him but he is more
than welcome here at Hillsdale College
please join me in welcoming mr. David
Satter
when Natalie's introduction is a good
example of why it's such a pleasure to
be at Hillsdale because I have
exceptionally charming students and
students also who are very interested in
learning I have returned to the United
States from London which is where I'm
living at the present time I decided
once I was expelled from this from
Russia I almost said the Soviet Union
because it was much more in the
character of the Soviet Union to expel
correspondence then in the character of
post-soviet Russia Russia claimed to be
beyond all that in fact it was a point
of pride that not a single American
correspondent had been expelled from
Russia since the fall of the Soviet
Union there were times in fact when
Russian officials even pointed to me as
an example of just how tolerant they
were but unfortunately for me their
tolerance finally broke and I was
expelled from from Russia in December of
last year the way this happened was
actually Kafka asked I left Moscow and
went to keeve in order to renew my visa
I had only been in Russia for three
months I could not have actually done
something during that period that would
have justified expulsion because during
that three-month period I it was all I
could do to organize an apartment open a
banking account and get furniture to get
set up to work I actually wrote very
little during that period I think that
the reason I was expelled was because
the authorities were concerned about
what I might do in the future not not
over what I had done since arriving in
September
incidentally in this regard I was at the
same time that the Russians were banning
me they were welcoming Edward Snowden
the NSA the NSA leaker and I did have
one one amusing moment actually two
amusing moments I'll start with the
first one the Snowden was claimed in
various interviews that he had no
contact with Russian intelligence this
this claim intrigued me because here I
was a person with years of experience in
Russia and the Soviet Union a fluent
Russian speaker and it took me months to
get through all the bureaucracy and a
valid visa and it took me months to get
through all of the bureaucracy in order
to establish residency in Moscow I
wondered how it was possible for Snowden
with no valid passport no visa no status
no knowledge of Russia and no knowledge
of Russian to go through to get through
all of this without help and in fact he
did have help he just assumed for some
reason that the nice people who were
helping him had no connection to Russian
intelligence which given given the
practices of Russia and the Soviet Union
is really the height of naivete on the
part of someone who was so clever about
betraying the trust of those who relied
on him to behave in a manner that that
took into regard the the welfare and
security of the entire country the other
thing of course was that after I was
expelled the Iranian news agency pars he
printed a story claiming that the reason
I was expelled was because I was
organizing an effort to kill Snowden and
I after this after this appeared and
this this did appear it's on the
internet you can find it if you you do a
search uh people began to ask me is it
true you were trying to kill Snowden
and in fact uh I had no no desire to
kill him and in fact I even feel that
would be the worst thing that could
happen that he really needs to be
returned to the u.s. for questioning but
in any case I decided that discretion in
this in this matter was the better part
of valor the the Iranians are just crazy
enough to believe their own inventions
so I just did not comment on that at all
when I left I left Moscow uh to renew my
visa in the Russian embassy in Kiev this
in itself was routine
I had to extend it for the next year
what wasn't routine was what happened
next in the in the embassy I handed in
the number of the telex sent by the
Russian Foreign Ministry which was
attached to the visa approval letter
this is a standard bureaucratic
procedure once they have that the number
of the telex they retrieve the attached
letter and process the visa which is
then stamped in your passport I know
this because I've gone through this
procedure many times went to the embassy
in the EFT and waited in line and handed
in the number and handed in my completed
application and the consular officer I
went to to get the letter and I was
sitting there for more than an hour he
finally came back and he said I'm sorry
there's no letter attached to this
number I said well what are you talking
about
I said there there has to be a letter
attached to the number they don't give
the number without a letter he said
that's true
and I said well
so tell me how long have you worked in
the consular service and he said -
twenty-one years said in those 21 years
have you ever had a case where there was
no letter attached to the to the
approval telex said no first time so I
called the called the Russian Foreign
Ministry from from Kiev I asked them
what's going on and they said don't
worry about a thing everything is taken
care of go back tomorrow there's a
diplomat who will explain the whole
situation solve this problem it's just
those bureaucrats you know in the in the
in the embassy and keeve they can't do
anything right so I mean I assume maybe
that was the case and I went back the
next day and I called called up to the
diplomat in question and he said I'd
like to read you something I have a
statement to read to you I realized that
that was not good news and he said that
the competent organs which is the
expression in Russia for the FSB the
security police have determined that
your presence on the territory of the
Russian Federation is undesirable in
you're banned from entering Russia and
with that I was the phurba came the
first person to be declared persona non
grata the first journalist the first
American journalist to be declared
persona non grata in Russia since the
Cold War now in fact this seemingly
isolated incident was not as isolated as
as it appeared it reflected a change in
policy because after all I'd been
getting visas despite the fact that I
had written many things that were
undesirable from the point of view of
the authorities and it had definitely
been Russian policy to create the
impression or to seek to create the
impression that Russia was a democratic
country that it was a country that could
be trusted by the West that it didn't do
things like expel foreign correspondents
but suddenly something happened there
was some type of sea change that made
that policy too risky in the eyes of the
Russian leaders and not long after I was
expelled a whole slew of other steps
were taken to crack down on Russian
human rights organizations foreigners
working in Moscow and and persons taking
part in protests suddenly Russia became
a more repressive place even in
comparison to the way it was previously
and I think the reason for that change
was not something that happened in
Russia but on the contrary the events in
neighboring Ukraine now all of the
former Soviet republics had with the EX
possible exception with the partial
exception of the Baltic republics have
certain things in common they all were
subjected to the kind of spiritual
sterilization and masks imposed mass
conformity that was obligatory under the
Soviet regime Soviet regime did not
recognize the value of an individual
individual was as a matter of doctrine
subordinated to the collective and
subordinated to the society his
interests were not important what was
important was the degree to which he
could serve the state Stalin in a famous
toast after the end of the Second World
War made this point explicitly he said
he wanted to salute the great Russian
people who played the greatest part in
the victory over Nazism each of them a
cog in the great machine of the state
and in fact that attitude toward the
individual was displayed in many many
other situations including by the way
during the war in the way in which the
lives of
viet soldiers were wasted the Germans
lost roughly one-third as many soldiers
as the Soviets even in battles in which
they lost to the Soviets the the the
lives of this was in fact one of the
reasons why the Soviet Union won because
it was so profligate with the lives of
its of its of its soldiers but in any
case this kind of degradation of the
individual and disregard for the value
of the individual has an effect on the
the moral fiber of society because after
all the sense of right and wrong is the
quality of an individual and throughout
the former Soviet Union in Russia in
Ukraine in Kyrgyzstan in Uzbekistan in
Azerbaijan with the fall of the Soviet
Union the pattern was the same yes there
was a change from a socialist economy to
a capitalist economy a state which was
based on complete state ownership was
succeeded by a state in which there was
private ownership but there was no
underlying moral change and as a result
what happened was an epidemic of
thievery and gangsterism and so what
what emerged from the wreckage of the
Soviet Union was not a set was not a set
of democratic states poised to develop
genuine and reliable legal institutions
but on the contrary a set of kleptocracy
x' in which a small group of people
pillaged the country for their own
benefit and to the great detriment of
the rest of the population
this pattern was particularly obvious in
Russia and Ukraine what was known as
privatization in Russia uh was actually
a process of of mass thievery because
all of the states property was in the
hands of impoverished bureaucrats and
there were very few people who had the
experience of operating in in in a
normal Kappa in a normal market economy
under those circumstances property
passed into the hands of those who
controlled it under the old regime or
those who had corrupt connections it
became indispensable in Russia and in
Ukraine to pay bribes and the cost of
the bribe was considered the starting
capital for the enterprise by buying an
official you could buy permission for
example to export oil which you
purchased at the domestic price which
was 1% of the world price and then sell
it at the world price the same applied
for many other raw materials with the
help of bribes you could induce the
government to deposit for example the
funds of the state Customs Service in
your bank and instead of paying salaries
you could lend the money out short term
at astronomical rates of interest while
the people who needed that money in
order to pay their bills and survive
waited months or even years to be paid
this was how the the new money class was
created in Russia as the way it was
created in Ukraine but a system that's
based on thievery
cannot convince the people who live
under it of its legitimacy everyone was
whit was a witness to how these fortunes
were created the country was driven to
cut these countries were driven into
poverty but a small group of multi
billionaires was created whose
lifestyles and values angered everyone
else the long-range consequences of this
were that the property that was acquired
in these in this manner was nowhere
regarded as legitimate and the lack of
legal institutions that made it possible
to seize property in this way invited a
new round of stealing and that's exactly
what took place in Russia it began in
2003 with the arrest of Mikhail
Khodorkovsky the richest person in
Russia at the time the head of the Yukos
oil company he was arrested because of
his attempts first of all to to change
the conditions of Russian capitalism
although in when it came to accumulating
wealth he was no different than anyone
else he was nonetheless alone among the
oligarchs in Russia among those who had
huge fortunes in understanding that the
rules of bandit capitalism were
disadvantageous in the long run and he
made a transition from bandit
capitalists to western-style manager and
an oil company owner his company yuccas
began to publish all of their all of
their results and all of their finances
they subjected themselves to Western
standards of accounting
and they soon were listed on the New
York Stock Exchange and in fact with the
rise in oil prices the value of that
company which was run along according to
Western principals was a rose
astronomically it the value I think if
I'm not wrong increased something like
seven or eight times in any case cutter
Kowski took another step which would
have been perfectly normal in the West
which is he began supporting opposition
political parties and particularly those
who could be relied on to support
legislation and programs that were
favorable to yuccas this was really too
much for the Putin leadership and Qatar
Kowski was arrested he was charged in
connection with violations that took
place earlier in the 1990s violations
that in fact were no different than
those are committed by everyone else in
Russia with large fortunes and he was
sent to Siberia and became a prisoner
for the next ten years his oil company
was divided up among Putin's cronies and
thus began the second wave of thievery
in Russia the second wave of private is
a forcible of privatization this time
forcible privatization which was given
the name of raiding and began to sweep
the country people saw how easy it was
to steal someone's oil company and
officials at all levels simply copied
the example of the officials at the top
if karakov ski was the wealthiest person
in Russia and if it was Putin in his
entourage that took away his oil company
well the same process took place at the
regional level at the local level at the
low
the level of a given town uh the the in
in the West when we talk about corporate
rating we're talking about a process
which results in a more efficient
distribution of resources and in which
both sides benefit rating in Russia
although it has the same name is
completely different in the case of of
Russia what took place was the use of
the organs of law enforcement to seize
someone's property this was done in a
very simple way usually I'm a minority
shareholder was infiltrated into the
board of directors of a company who then
brought charges usually in some distant
jurisdiction of malfeasance the with the
help of a corrupt judge of a court
decision was issued in the cost of the
court decision is the most expensive
part of of carrying out the raid at that
point with the with the illegitimate
Court decision in hand the raider
returns to the company he wants to take
over rents the local police and simply
appropriates the the given factory or
enterprise that began to happen all over
Russia at the same time in neighboring
Ukraine the process uh ripened but did
not occur because as a result of what
was called the the Orange Revolution in
2004 Ukraine unlike Russia is a
regionally divided country in which a
large part of the country up until the
second world war was European
it was part of Poland
and this part of the Ukraine the Western
Ukraine is Western in its Orang
orientation and Ukrainian nationalists
and are definitely determined to defend
the national integrity of Ukraine
whereas in the the eastern part of the
country there are many Russians ethnic
Russians who were settled there
especially after the 1932-1933
artificial famine in which millions of
people died the as a result of this
split in the country there was real
competitive voting in Ukraine and in
2004 Viktor Yanukovych was elected
president on the basis of massive
falsification of the results of the
election this triggered a huge protests
in Kiev which came known as the Orange
Revolution and the crisis which resulted
was resolved when Viktor Yuschenko the
candidate the unsuccessful candidate was
elected in a reelection Yushchenko's
period in office was one of the reasons
why the process of reprieve 'it is a
ssin the process that took place in
russia after the arrest of Khodorkovsky
was was delayed by a number of years but
Yushchenko had the bad luck of being
president of Ukraine during the world
economic crisis of 2007 to 2009 during
that period Ukraine's gross national
product fell by 15% it suffered perhaps
more than any other post-soviet state
from the consequences of the economic
crisis industrial production fell 30
and in the aftermath of this economic
disaster from which Ukraine began to
recover but has not recovered fully
Yanukovych despite his record of having
falsified the results of the 2004
election in 2010 was elected president
Yanukovych had an interesting history he
began as a petty criminal in the Donetsk
Oblast and he became aligned with a man
named Rinat Akhmetov who worked as an
enforcer for a local gangster named
Brogan who was blown up along with six
of his bodyguards
in a crime in which Chuck met off was
was widely suspected in any case in the
aftermath of Brogan's death Akhmetov
took over much much of his holdings in
the eastern ukraine and eventually
became the richest man in ukraine his
protege in his Bullitt his political
Protege was none other than Yanukovych
and Yanukovych when he became president
of Ukraine in 2010 brought with him the
methods and psychology of the Donetsk
underworld if in other parts of the
country privatization was crooked in
dunt the Donetsk Oblast it was bloody
and carried out with the help of
massacres and contract killings on a
very large scale as President Yanukovych
began the process which was also taking
place in Russia but in a less perhaps a
less focused form of bringing the
country's property into his own hands he
did this by first of all packing the
Constitutional Court with the help of
deputies who were financially dependent
on the government using the new
constitution
court to change the structure of the
country from presidential
parliamentarian parliamentary it had
been changed to that from presidential
by yannick by Yushchenko changed it back
to presidential and uh he then using
again his influence with the courts
adopted a series of laws that deprived
not only ordinary citizens but members
of the Parliament of the of the
protection of the law and what happened
next was simply extortion and
expropriation of property on the scale
of the whole country
people were told were given an offer for
their property which was or for their
enterprises which was far below their
true value and if they if they refused
to accept that they received a lower
offer and if they refused to accept that
they were they were brought to court or
imprisoned the in the course of three
years Yanukovych's son Alexander a
dentist became the one of the wealthiest
people in Ukraine a multi-billionaire
when he when Yanukovych was asked how
was possible to amass such wealth in
three years he Yanukovych said he's a
very gifted businessman in fact the the
reputation of Yanukovych his family and
their henchmen was such that many people
began Xperia T at the local level simply
saying I'm from Alexander no one no one
bothered to check those claims because
they were perfectly perfectly feasible
but this concentrated and and widespread
seizure of property was only possible
because of the corruption
the cysts of the the system of law
enforcement and that had other
consequences in the town of Airy Africa
the first sign of popular discontent
appeared a young girl was kidnapped
raped and almost beaten to death by two
members of the local police and then the
crime was covered up by higher-ups in
the in in the city this finally was too
much because there had been two similar
murders in the last three years in the
same town and people began to protest
and tried to take over the the police
building later they marched on Kiev and
demonstrated in the Maidan which was
that my don is the Ukrainian word for
square Maidan Nezalezhnosti Independence
Square where the later demonstrations
took place this was a sign of the fact
that the population had finally had
enough and it was also an indication of
just how out of control the police and
law enforcement was were because this
was not the only case of a woman being
raped there were cases of women being
beaten raped murdered and either by
members of law enforcement or by persons
connected to the authorities the
situation had reached the point in
Ukraine where no one felt safe no one
felt that they had a business that they
could be sure they that they could
continue to own and run there was no
security of property but and perhaps
more important there was no sense that
that there they would be protected in
their personal lives
anyone dragged into a police station on
any pretext yet had no defense
whatsoever and all of this was rooted in
the lawless system that was that was
created by privatization in issue
but greatly increased and strengthened
under Yanukovych
so therefore when Yanukovych announced
in November 2013 that after having
promised to sign an association
agreement with the European Union that
Ukraine was not in fact going to join
Europe and when he did so without giving
any explanation or promising anything
further in the way of ongoing
negotiations demonstrations took place
in Kiev which were greatly exacerbated
when the police attacked a group of
students in the Maidan square and
savagely beat them even though they were
peaceful and demonstrating only for
Ukraine's adherence to the association
agreement which Yanukovych himself had
promised that was the beginning that was
the beginning of the nationwide revolt
that led to the overthrow of Yanukovych
that was the Ukrainian anti-criminal
revolution I was there in December and
addition to applying for my visa I kept
a diary some of my entries appeared on
National Review Online in National
Review Online about what was going on in
Ukraine at that time the the main square
in the centre of the city was turned
into a medieval fortress in which a
completely self-contained city and which
provided he which had its own sentinels
its own guards its own system of
security its own food service its own
hospital even its own prayer rooms and
it's even its lectures and and movie
hall and I should add that my movie was
shown in the in the in the my done on
Christmas Eve
the overthrow of Yanukovych was followed
as we know by the seizure of Crimea by
Russia
and by the invasion of eastern Ukraine
with a which was which was accompanied
by a whole series of atrocities
including of course the shooting down of
Malaysian airliner 17 over eastern
Ukraine it is a testimony to the
complete disregard of the individual in
Russia that the Russians could have
given such the the book anti-aircraft
system to a collection of terrorists
like that terrorists were under pressure
from Ukrainian from the Ukrainian Air
Force they themselves did not have
planes but they the area over eastern
Ukraine is one of the busiest air air
air traffic routes in the world and
these systems have a friend or foe a
program which identifies whether a
potential target is a friend or a foe
and they are hooked into the net into
the nationwide aircraft monitoring
system but they only work in within the
boundaries of the country for which
they're designated so to take a Russian
anti-aircraft system and move it to
Ukraine and then put it in the hands of
terrorists or even if it was
professional Russians Russian soldiers
who were operating it nonetheless I
meant that you were accepting the idea
that any shot fired from that system
could bring down a civilian airliner
which is exactly what happened
the in addition to the shooting down of
mh17 there was indiscriminate shelling
and indiscriminate beatings and torture
of ordinary civilians now it must be
pointed out in fact that the Russians
were not the only ones the Russian
separatist forces who for whom weapons
were pouring in over the border were not
the only ones engaging in indiscriminate
shelling Ukrainians are also former
Soviet citizens and there was
indiscriminate shelling from the
Ukrainian side - but in the matter of a
cup of couple of weeks at least three
thousands people overwhelmingly
civilians were dead the there is now a
ceasefire so-called in place although a
bitter fight is continuing for the
Donetsk Airport in eastern Ukraine but
the fighting can break out again at any
minute and it's already served its
purpose which is to destabilize the new
government of Ukraine which is seeking
to align itself with the West there have
been various theories that have been
advanced by Western specialists as to
end by various observers as to why
Russia did this why would Russia which
is a very a which is a kindred nation to
Ukraine where people have Ukrainian
relatives where many people are of
Ukrainian descent why would it initiate
a civil war between people who are so
similar and provoke such a bloodbath
and some have said well it's because
Putin is trying to re-establish the
Soviet Union others have said that Putin
wants to be a new Napoleon or a new
Stalin some people have suggested that
Putin wants to take over all of Ukraine
but the reality I think is different I
think what's at stake here
is a desire to make sure that the
Russian people do not follow the
Ukrainian example the example of a
peaceful spontaneous self-organizing
self-regulating anti-criminal revolution
in Ukraine that succeeded in
overthrowing a criminal clique that was
in charge of the country is exactly the
example that the Russian leaders don't
want the Russian people to see and to
take seriously and yet the Keynesian is
that the conditions in Russia are really
the same yes it's true that Ukraine is
smaller that the the abuses of the
Yanukovych and his family were more
visible than those of Putin in his
clique although not that much more
visible it's also true that Ukraine is
poorer because Russia has national
resources but the basic imprint of a
kleptocratic regime which has no regards
only to feed itself with complete
disregard for the interests of the
country that condition is the same and
in fact it exists in the other Soviet
were former Soviet republics as well and
so Putin has turned to the tried and
true method of distracting the attention
of the population which is to start a
war and by the way this is nothing new
in 1994 Yeltsin are facing increasing
unpopularity because of the economic
reforms in Russia started the first
Chechen war 1999 to bring Putin to power
he started the second chechen war 2008
to boost the the status of the his place
warmer dmitry medvedev who took over as
president for one term started the war
against georgia and now in order to
distract the population from what the
anti criminal revolution in ukraine they
started this new war
the difficulty is that starting a war is
a very unpredictable enterprise and it's
full of risk it is true that now Putin's
popularity rating is is astronomical but
it the the Tsar was experienced the same
thing at the beginning of the first
world war in 1914
three years later he was deposed the
situation in Russia is basically
dysfunctional just as it was in Ukraine
and it's dysfunctional because it's a
country without law and it's a country
with warped values only a restoration of
decent values and the rule of law holds
the possibility of curing the endemic
problems in Russia that are eventually
going to lead to a systemic crisis and
no amount of artificial chauvinism
artificially induced chauvinism or or or
militarism is going to change the course
of history in the long run so I think
that we now face a country which is a
challenge to the United States Russia
has shown that it's willing to tear up
the post-war consensus and for the first
time seized territory of another country
a country with which it had literally
250 treaties all of which were based
either directly or indirectly on
acknowledgement of Ukraine's territorial
sovereignty and integrity Russia shown
that it has no respect for truth and it
is engaging in massive falsification all
of it directed against both the
Ukrainians and the US which despite our
naive policy of reset is considered to
be the the evil force behind the
Ukrainians and
and the inspiration for their report for
their revolt the in order to deal with
this situation we have to bear in mind
that anything based on falsehood to this
degree is going to be unstable
and Russia is a country with nuclear
weapons
Russia's the second most powerful
nuclear state as we know and it's it's
military resources are formidable if the
situation in rah inside Russia begins to
unravel as a result of people
understanding what the people in Ukraine
began to understand that they're being
dominated by a criminal kalique and that
that clique acts only in its own
interests and not in the interests of
the curved country there could begin to
be serious unrest in Russia and serious
unrest in Russia threatens not just the
stability of Russia but because Russia
is so powerful that it it threatens the
whole world in conclusion I'd like to
say that and I think it's improper to
say this here at Hillsdale where
individual rights and the importance of
the individual and his freedom is taken
is it understood and taken seriously
that our greatest gift right now
to the Russian people under these
circumstances is our American moral
influence the influence of a society in
which despite everything there is the
rule of law and the individual is taken
seriously and can't just be trampled
underfoot and treated as raw material
for the realization of the of the aims
of the political leaders it's going to
be one of the challenges of the American
political system and it's important to
keep this in mind as we look ahead to
the next presidential election to find
ways to insist on that our government
understand the real issues that are at
stake and to use that influence in ways
that can be effective we owe that to the
Russian people who are going to need the
help at the outside world and I think in
terms of our long-term security we owe
it to ourselves well thank you very
thank you very much
Thank You mr. sadder for your talk we
will now have some time for questions
and answers so if you have a question
please raise your hand and we will bring
you the microphone Thank You mr. sadder
victor yushchenko was that the leader
that was poisoned with polonium and his
face was horribly disfigured prior to
the Orange Revolution yeah he was he was
poisoned with dioxin but yeah
yes was that the KGB that did it or your
your this is I mean it's one of the
ironies of the situation that after you
Shenko was elected he was very lethargic
about uncovering exactly who was
responsible but people who are familiar
with with the situation and particularly
the high degree of expertise that the
KGB always had when it came to poisoning
people I believe that he was that it was
Russian intelligence
that was responsible it may well be that
he feared that if he pursued it too
energetically they might finish the job
thank you for that excellent
presentation I've been hearing a lot in
both regular media and alternative media
about the unpacking of the US dollar
from oil and the trade agreements
between China and Russia exchanging
goods and resources in their own
currencies and not using the US dollar
and my question for you is can you share
your insight and what you understand
about the economics of the situation as
to what the global war of fiat
currencies is right now between the
western central banking system and
what's going on in Eurasia with China
and Russia and also maybe even some the
challenges with the Middle East and
attempts to go on to gold standard in
Africa and how all these things are
affecting what we hear in the news about
Wars and you know unrest in the Middle
East and that type of thing
so I just would love to get your insight
on that I'm not sure I have much insight
I think that I mean it's clear the the
Russians have spoken before about their
desire to lessen their dependence on the
dollar and in in light of the the
sanctions that have been imposed on the
Russian economy they they may very well
be considering those options seriously
America's great reserve weapon is its
influence over the world banking system
if if we decide to go further in the way
of sanctions the US has the ability
really to paralyze the Russian financial
system and it may well be with with that
with that potential in mind that
Russia's begin beginning to consider
these alternatives there back here you
talked about the need for some sort of
moral regeneration in Russian society
could you comment on the state of the
Russian Orthodox Church in its place in
society since Vladimir Putin has taken
power thanks for that question this is
something that is is always asked
because Putin regularly surrounds
himself with the hierarchs of the
Russian Orthodox Church he he one would
get the impression if one watched rush
of nothing but Russian television that
Putin was one of the most pious and
deeply religious people in the world he
doesn't take a move he doesn't make a
move without having a Russian Orthodox
priest dressed in full religious regalia
at his side he attends all religious
services for all religious holidays make
sure that make sure that he's
photographed but the Russian Orthodox
Church itself at least if we talk about
its hierarchy is deeply corrupt I'll
give you an example during the 1990s the
Russian Orthodox Church was given a
concession they were give allowed the
right to import alcohol and tobacco
without paying customs duties which and
then they of course sold sold the
alcohol tobacco made huge fortunes and a
lot of the the leading Church hierarchs
became very very rich despite the fact
that smoking in the Russian Orthodox
Church is considered to be a sin not
only one of there was a sign of just how
rich they became when Kirill who is the
the patriarch of the Russian Orthodox
Church was was photographed with a
$30,000 watch and that photograph was
photoshopped by the patriarchy to remove
the watch that the the the the watch
from his wrists but they forgot to
remove the reflection of the watch from
the polished table where he was sitting
so it was obvious not only that he had
the watch but they tried was trying to
conceal the watch but the the there are
thousands of ordinary Russian Orthodox
priests who really play a positive role
in the country and who helped people a
lot and a really a source of comfort and
solace and bring some spirituality and
religiosity to people in Russia but the
russian orthodox hierarchy but those
people the the ordinary priests are very
unworldly they don't have much to do
with politics the hierarchy however
which is firmly connected to the regime
is totally corrupt ignores all real
moral issues
and focuses on the gay issue now they'd
have not denounced Russian corruption
they've not opposed the killing of
civilians even when those civilians were
were Russians as for example during the
carpet bombing of Grozny the capital of
Chechnya in the nineteen 1995
20,000 people killed in five weeks
they've not they've not even tried to do
something about the country's rampant
alcoholism which is destroying the
social fabric in fact not only that they
even sell the alcohol but the but but
when it comes to the gay issue they they
found something that they feel that they
can be indignant indignant about and on
that issue they use words like satanic
depraved and so on and so forth now it's
not my purpose here to get into a
discussion of that particular issue but
rather to point out that it's a
diversionary maneuver that that in fact
the question of the of the status of
gays in Russia is not a big issue
because gays they're generally speaking
are afraid to to advertise their
orientation and generally speaking it's
not very visible in Russian society but
it is visible in the West and this gives
you know Putin and the Russian Orthodox
Church something that they can use to
say that we are actually morally
superior to the West forget about all
the other things that we do and
unfortunately there are many people in
the West and not many people there's
some people in the West who are gullible
enough to swallow this
yes um thank you for the speech it was
wonderful I thought I saw on reddit that
a lot of the troops were called back to
their barracks within the last couple of
days is that another diversionary thing
or do you think the there's a response
to the pressure from the economic side
that he's that Putin's dealing with it's
hard to say
we we don't really know what motivates
the Russian leadership because it's in a
very opaque process but you can't keep
troops mobilized forever and the fact
that they've been pulled back doesn't
mean that they won't be redeployed and
even if they've been pulled back it
doesn't mean that the fighting is going
to stop or that the collection of
quote-unquote volunteers in fact they
emptied the prisons and contractors in
eastern Ukraine who are Russian citizens
are going to stop fighting I mean the
fighting continues the particularly
around the Donetsk Airport the the
confrontation continues there are still
territory that's held officially there's
a ceasefire but 300 people have been
killed during the so-called ceasefire so
I would say that it uh it doesn't mean a
lot is it yes it has happened you're
right I wouldn't it doesn't mean that
the crisis is over it doesn't mean it
certainly doesn't mean that the Russian
government has given up the effort to
destabilize Ukraine and prevent Ukraine
from pursuing a Western path of
development David the edge as you know
I'm over here I'm looking for you but
I'm on if you look to your right to my
right yes well there you are right well
yeah as you know I was at Hoover last
year and was next door to John Dunlop
and upstairs from Paul Gregory and when
all these things happened
we talked every day about it and one of
the things that they agreed on was that
Putin once he made these moves could not
stop and and the reason they argued was
that the economy in Russia was stagnant
and it was going to get worse after the
seizure of Ukraine because there was
going to be nervousness in the capital
markets and a withdrawal of support
which means that the economy would get
worse and that Putin would derive his
legitimacy from conquest from expansion
and their argument was he simply
couldn't stop which meant that it would
go to the Baltics do you think that's
right well I don't even even from a
distance I don't like to disagree with
my friends John Dunlop and Paul Gregory
so you put me in a difficult spot ah I
think that the Baltics would be a
tougher nut to crack for the simple
reason that these are NATO members I
think that there there are other
candidates besides the Baltics Moldova
Ukraine itself Kazakhstan this is all
there in the realm of speculation of
course the the the they will do whatever
they think is in the interest of their
survival by this I mean the Putin regime
and if the economic sanctions are
sufficiently destabilizing they could
make concessions even in in the case of
of Ukraine in order to rid themselves of
of those sanctions on the other hand
ridding ridding themselves of those
sanctions may come at the price of
alienating the extreme nationalists who
have now been unleashed in Russia so I
would not be as cat I would not be as
categorical
about it I think that they will do
whatever they think is in their
interests and what's in their interests
will depend on a very unpredictable and
evolving set of circumstances we have
time for one final question a person
that I know that has contact with Russia
once said very recently that the only
patriotic Russian is a drunk Russian
what is the state of patriotism in
Russia among common people well I don't
know who said that um but I don't agree
with that
the Russians are patriotic and
unfortunately their patriotism has been
exploited and misused the another factor
though is that to a certain extent the
suppression of individuals the lack of
individual rights is compensated in the
minds of Russia Russians by the
greatness of their state the French
writer the Marquis de ku Steen in the
19th century writing about Russia said
the slave on his knees dreams of world
domination and I hate I was in the
Soviet Union I remember standing in the
lines at the the Senate in what in the
grocery stores and they get what they
call the gastronomes anybody would be
long lines as people would wait to buy
food and some what I remember once
someone said is how long can these go on
standing in these lines and woman turned
him and said don't worry the whole world
is afraid of us
and so it's there is widespread
patriotism it's not just it's not
confined to drunks but although people
become more patriotic with the more
they've had to drink but it's it's also
a reflection of the idea that the very
unhealthy idea that well yeah it's okay
that we don't have full liberty as
individuals but look at look at our
powerful state and on that that that
that attitude
is indeed very widespread thank you